[Musique]
marolles petit village près de lisieux
une ferme pas comme les autres ici les
animaux sont rois
depuis longtemps jacqueline breton les
aime et respecte comme de vieux amis de
cette amitié entre hal et les animaux
sont nés de nouveau rapport de nouveaux
liens mais surtout une nouvelle
sensibilité désormais où qu'elles soient
chaque ligne breton perçoit leur
bien-être ou ressent leur souffrance où
j'ai pris connaissance ce jour je fais
la télépathie avec une brebis
elle était coincée entre deux arbres je
ne la voyais pas et je suis parti en
courant parce qu'elle souffrait l et s
était abîmé la cuisse et c'est là où
j'ai senti je me suis posé des questions
après qu'est ce qui m'avait fait courir
et puis il va c'est là je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais fait date et les
parties avec elle
beaucoup de choses se sont greffées sur
cette chose là toute la journée dans la
nature
eh bien on a une communication à la
longue on a une communication avec la
nature
[Musique]
cette communication avec la nature
jacqueline breton l'a établi de manière
peu ordinaire avec la forêt tout a
commencé un beau matin lorsqu'un arbre
au loin la plaie je me suis sentie
attirée là le matin donc ça m'a fait
sortir de mon lit matin très tôt comme
vers 6h30 safran ncaa et pieds nus et à
temps et si ses traits à la rose et même
en plein mois d'août c'était la semaine
du hautmont des cases où je suis 100
semaines avant le 15 on va être en 90
quelque chose comme ça et pendant toute
la semaine on a appelé l'énergie du
corps
on m'a fait inspiré
d'abord
et nous les énergies brûlé fallait
d'abord éliminé après ça se recharger et
après ça je pouvais recevoir des
messages faisant plus loin il y à être
qui est blessé et bien un jour en
passant en dessous j'ai eu envie de
m'asseoir et bien l'année dernière tout
simplement à cette époque et il m'a dit
pourquoi faut-il que les hommes soient
si dur avec les arbres et c'est le
lendemain que j'ai appris que dans la
forêt amazonienne on abattait un million
d'hectares par an
[Musique]
mais
y'en a un qui m'a appelé parce qu'il
était blessé je l' ai su qu un frère qui
m'a attiré c'est très long parce que un
arbre qui est 100 à des ondes
particulier un aaron qui est malade
ces zones sont complètement changé et
bien c'est peut être ma attiré je suis
allé vers lui il y avait un morceau de
métal dedans et j'ai réussi à l'enlever
ce être là ne m'avait pas appelé à
n'importe quel moment ni importé galère
c'est à dire qu'il m'a appelé le jour de
la pleine lune et au moment juste sous
le soleil donnait sur sable
non
où
quelquefois les heures une bâtir et je
me sens obligée de je vais vous faire
voir comment voyez toute la ligne des
chakras tout le corps qui parle du faux
un vus jusqu'à l'os du bas du corps
comme ça et après ce but on un certain
moment et a prévenu que je me sens bien
rechargées il ya une communion qui s'est
faite avec la ça vous étonne pas de le
fait que les arbres vous parle à notre
but
non il faut pas apparaître dans la
nature il faut vivre avec la nati moi
c'est un peu différent
[Musique]